[Music]
so stocked so jiggly hey guys Dinka and
today i am gonna be making some super
fluffy souffle pancakes I've been seeing
these pancakes pop up everywhere both on
the internet and in real life they're
basically exactly like what you would
imagine this beautiful cross between a
souffle and a pancake when I had a
chance to try them that first bite I
feel like that's the closest we would
ever get to taking a bite of a cloud
it's that airy this trend actually
started in Japan and when it all first
began there were lines out the door
every single day for people who wanted a
bite of this fluffy cloud like pancakes
since I will be traveling anytime soon
and I really want to taste of it I'm
gonna be making it at home let's get
started a lot of these ingredients will
be the same ones you need when you make
your usual pancakes we need some eggs
some milk oil flour sugar vanilla and a
little bit of baking powder
pretty pretty straightforward
ingredients it's more of the steps that
might be a little more tricky but we'll
be able to do it so the first step is to
separate your egg yolks from your egg
whites I'm going to put that in here
we're going to add milk and oil then I'm
also adding in some vanilla just to give
it a little boost of flavor and that's
all there is for a wet ingredients list
and combine them that's about good we
can add in our dry ingredients it's
adding in flour baking powder then let
it's snow I always like sifting dry
ingredients and makes your batter a
little smoother this is what we're
working with right now so little on the
thicker side that's okay because we'll
be mixing it with our meringue mixture
set this aside for now and I'm gonna
start working with our egg whites I'm
using my stand mixer for this part
because I don't have a hand mixer and I
know if I whisk this by hand to get
stiff peaks I will not have a hand
anymore by the end of this and we'll
slowly gradually add in our sugar
[Music]
okay this is always the best thing to
watch what we're gonna do now is
basically combine our fluffing around
here with our pancake batter I think my
pancake batter got a little little slick
scooping a little bit first and it's
okay if you're a little rougher here
making sure this is well combined
instantly making it paler in color this
also looks like what I remember it to be
when I wash the people other restaurants
do it
look at this ribbony texture this is
looking pretty good
we're just going to slowly fold this all
in now you guys probably understand why
the pancake has all that airiness it's
exactly because of the meringue all that
air we just whipped into these egg
whites that's what's going to give us
that perfect cloud like airiness later I
can feel how just like light it's
getting this is a bowl fluffiness this
looks good enough to eat already oh my
goodness mesmerizing you don't want to
over mix this so we're gonna stop what's
important though is that we have to go
immediately into making the pancakes if
you let this sit for too long it's gonna
get watery and nobody wants watery
pancakes I'm going to get everything
ready now so that we can start does I
have my fluffy fluffy batter here scoop
them out like that Wow
I'm so tempted to just eat it like this
first one is right here I'm just adding
a little bit I do one there too on the
other side I'll let it sit right there I
think even more on there because you
want it to have again that volume so
that it looks like I'm being greedy but
I promise it's for volume we're gonna do
the same with this guy over here this is
what I saw them do at the restaurants
too this is what they look like now you
can see they're like little bread
dough's with a little top and a bottom
add a little bit of water
because it creates steam which will keep
the Pankey cooking without drying it out
and I'm gonna cover it up I'm also using
a pan to act as my lid it's a hack that
I think works perfectly if you don't
have a lid it is time to check on them
it smells so good and here you guys time
for liftoff oh wow they have really
expanded holy moly I don't want to miss
this up this is always the tricky part
and this is this is what I got for now
okay sorry I shouldn't play with my food
whoa
it is very very jiggly oh all right I
got two jiggly boys here whoa this looks
pretty good
it smells really promising it looks
really promising she's gonna add a
little bit of water again I'm just gonna
cover it up
one last time oh so excited this process
does take a lot of time because they
have to make it to order the batter
can't just sit there
pancakes can't just sit there a lot of
respect for the vendors who do this I
cannot get over this smell though
should be almost done all right let's
give it a look tah-dah is it jiggly yes
it is I gotta show you the violin a
beautiful volume right there it is such
a blessing to be able to smell this at
home you guys oh my god I'm so tempted I
just eat it like this it's so stocked
and it's so jiggly all right getting too
excited again I am going to no not tally
I am going to quickly plate this up
before it deflates too much and then we
can see what it looks like but this is
already really really exciting
[Music]
it is finally done might have spent a
little too much time decorating but I'm
super proud of what this looks like now
looks like winter wonderland okay how
fluffy that is it's still warm and it
still smells amazing so before it's too
late
I'm gonna take a bite it is so light oh
my god there's almost like no resistance
when you bite into it this one really
just feels like when you're eating a
souffle and just melts in your mouth
another bite here
it's all that air in there it's not just
the thickness barely feels like anything
right now
mmm it's so so so satisfying I am not
kidding I am literally going to finish
this whole thing by myself I need to
stop eating you don't have to wait until
you're traveling to be able to enjoy the
plate of beautiful fluffy souffle
so please do give this a try I'm so
excited to see you guys make this at
home and I will see you guys next time
[Music]